blog mas numero 16 teoricamente la
macchina da di ieri avete visto
pochissimo perché di base ci sono dei
momenti in cui è anche bello spegnerla
la videocamera
dopo il blog ma sti neri non mi va di
fare nulla anche perché oggi il rullo di
tamburi possiamo dirlo è il nostro
mesiversario la luce della chiamata di
tiro comunque non riusciamo a fare
niente stiamo mangiando e basta ma che
fatto allora il pancarrè salsa dietro
grado tra l'altro gorgonzola e
mascarpone fette di salame lancia
pochissimo ma è fatto tutto qualcosa
ripieno certo ma con lui ha detto no il
coltello come si versate la mannaia sul
tagliere ha fatto schifo però chi mi ha
appena promesso una roba che mi
preparava il cremino con la murales
carnevale guardatelo se ne vada giusto
per la scusa ma che sapranno anni a me
le piattole cosa piede piatto del legno
che manieri sarà mite botte ti servono
la romana in legno ok vabbè tanto
pulisco io mi porti anche a me later
pulisce lui per sono tutti sotto i
cugini ma non pulisce per poi uscito
compilata comunque e di come le parti
una è un piatto a camme e tu di plastica
legno plastica legno plastica lui fette
enormi io gli scarpini bianchi palla
federica dove hai detto esagerato un
processo gente ti ho detto sì lo so
frutto tra l'altro vorrei esagerare e
bassi invece non mangiare un morso
esagera un pezzettino le potete lasciare
davvero veramente sempre poi alla fine
rimane tutto tu vede testando questa
credo che possa essere forse le giornate
più brutte della mia vita
anche perché luigi nel detto season
mi ha detto donna ha detto voglio alla
crema al mascarpone ha detto in che
senso dai che vuoi dire ed è troppo
anche per i gelatieri che cosa fra sta
preparando sul serio mi ha fatto due
così adesso me ne state prende sul serio
ora di colpo per le telecamere fai finta
che non la volessi sul serio lavoro tu
lo fai solo per le telecamere
tu lo fai solo per il like lo fai solo
per quello più che altro pensa non così
scontata e cosa ci fai col mio maglione
è una foto ti volevi fare per il alcol
pace nei ripari rai che la per fare
questa foto allora ecco ci voleva
abbiamo aspettato tempo per queste
ringraziamenti dovuti ed fiom a
stampanti pesce cappone come festeggiare
in maniera meravigliosa questo
mesiversario è a casa a guardarci bene
lì
e questi fiori non so manco per me ma
luigi ripresi per mia mamma infatti le
vie di spese non basterà salutare
salutare adesso tanto guarda tutti i
miei video sul serio è un messaggio di
natale si un bacio di un presto con la
quale dilettanti barbara d'urso
hai un messaggio da dare a mia madre
siamo arrivati alla stazione che poi ci
vedremo vedremo ai propri settimane cioè
natale di questo compleanno
no ragazzi mi sta mettendo una crisi
creando è anche questo e sta uscendo una
macchina per esempio dice motivo mandare
il regalo di natale che poteva portare
il rio del compleanno
non lo so facevo io testo d'aiuto perché
così difficile ti regalo
il mio amore non ti basta sono tornato
dalla stazione arriva 0 davvero voglia
di fare questo passo a guglielmo lampade
far suo blog max va bene lo faccio io
blog ma iniziano alla grande
mas numero 16 buonanotte
ma il discorso di base e che in giornate
come queste che sono quelle del mio
mesiversario usano le 20 eventi quindi
sto per dire una cosa saggia le persone
essere bravi a capire anche quando
spegnere la videocamera a quando
staccarsi dai social per ribery il
sociale sapere come si svolta lo scrivo
su instagram
non so come smontare questo modo
ragazzi ci stiamo annoiando come i pazzi
facciamola live blog ma se questa è la
camera del blog ma la ripresa sara
marasso cloud è una cosa ma che si fa
posso fare ora essere annoiato con
questi cielo torneo di pozza cos'è forza
è un gioco che abbiamo inventato tempo
fa ma basta avere una palletta morbida
del cane un corridoio
abbiamo tutto un lavandino si giocavano
davanti tutto ma noi giocheremo con la
bacinella e la riempiendo d'acqua perché
puzza penso che questo passaggio da
evitare però immagino si debba lanciare
la palla e certelli beccare la bozza
bisogna fare 10 ma non si lanciano le
mani in cosa si lanciano si e si caccia
io ho capito ma io lo so farlo con le
mani lo faccio con i piedi ragazzi a
questo punto su bisogno caminos il piano
non è più facile se volete far altro che
di ne ho capito però in questo modo come
facciamo una sezione una mancia prende
la palla si prende la palla e aprendo è
in questa posizione
questo punto vi girate se sistemate ok e
siete pronti va bene alcuni capito bene
semplicemente adesso non vi ho detto la
regola più importante che nelle curie
faccio pozza cioè mi metto la pa la
palla alla pozza rossa come a1 devo dire
pozzi mamma il mostro io come si fa a
pozza ed io
porca miseria pronto vanta st facciamo
qualcos'altro lira gioco più brutto nata
perché tu crei così accompagni la palla
così invece di viti reatina fine
facciamo qualcosa facciamo dei giochi
natalizi sentiamoci vivi che stai
facendo errico 6 su instagram è che ti
guardi agli interessi forse c'è qualcosa
che non sappiamo eri costa su instagram
che ci sono inter gabi smith ea porcelle
comodo enrico stassi
ma che cosa voleva fare mangiare 35
cheeseburger ma c'era un attimo non
abbiamo mangiati 54 alla fine stimati di
cibo ci hanno mandato a noi due
apprendere di cheeseburger ancora 40 cv
che questi se magna
ma poiché problemi avete potete mangiare
46 prima c'era una cina vedere andiamo
per le strade prendere 40
io ancora sono sconvolto c'è marco
sconvolto marito ma oddio senti allora
per favore
cioè che stiamo facendo mar inquadriamo
quella macchina gli assassini possono
certo perché non ci crede perché voglio
avere la faccia di dirle 40 cisse e
voglio sentire che mi dice scusa ma che
senso ha posso prendere un panino
normale io non sarebbe idoneo buonasera
allora 40 cheeseburger e 40 lo so si
effettivamente un bel numero si è
disperata
non so in che modo a venirci incontro st
chiedere un bel risultato dando fuoco
alla cucina e discovery na mite nemmeno
è possibile
beh non è che abbiamo chiesto però 40
nuovi alacran nuova alla grande poi ti
volevamo chiedere anche un ferry ha gli
smarties e basta vergogna
c'è pure lei disperata non sapeva che
cosa per il sar è attivo da chiedere e
le ha chiesto ed erano 40 panatta la
paura canta
a disp n 40 cheeseburger sta per
sentirci sia gli occhiali
[Musica]
non lo sapevo anch'io c'era mai
perché perché
no a chi ama vedere così non è
no no kids e ti prego non più
ma come non poteva bene prossima volta
puoi vincere
achille ho capito questa volta la
prossima volta puoi vincere
di cosa
di rimboccarsi le maniche e cercare
capito dvd di farcela allora ti ho detto
adesso andata così ma domani magari
potrebbe andare meglio non trovi scusami
adesso non ti ho capito i killer ma se
così disfattista ti prego chi il milan
inizia a parlare vi prego che con le tue
cose che mi mignini
achille in indegnamente capisco ciao
sono quelli di guardia
no grazie qualcuno anno non sono stata
la nostra di pixel
il milione
vabbè ci fidiamo sfidiamoci di
archiviano da quelli tranquillità della
figlia spero che non dobbiamo ritornare
speriamo di non tornare a riscuotere un
processo mancante sarebbe registrato nel
senso perché dobbiamo essere quelli che
vanno frenati primis potevamo chiedergli
42 anno alla sua natura cc grazie mille
ragioni istituti di lavoro a boy porci
ragazzi che vuole vuoi vai su chi vuole
ragazzi poi eccolo eccolo 123 a posto e
dopo aver curato tutti e 40 c e sporgere
continua a giocare d'azzardo urlare ci
vediamo domani alle 14 con un urlo molto
interessante perché parlerò di chirurgia
estetica di medicina estetica e vado a
trovare prima persona questa donna
ciao